>> SLATKIN: So this is talk on making your
application real-time with PubSubHubbub. We
call it Hubbub for short often. So if you
hear--as referring to it that's what we're
talking about. We also sometimes call it PuSH
for short or PSHB depending on who you ask.
So, yeah--okay, so yeah my name is Brett Slatkin.
I'm a software engineer on the Google App
Engine team. PubSubHubbub is something that
me and Brad Fitzpatrick is also here to came
up with, along with some other people in the
community like Martin Atkins from Six Apart
and we've been working on a lot with the community
to improve it and build it out, incorporate
feedback and so on. So today, we're going
to be talking about a number of things. To
start off, if you want to look at notes or
know how to tweet about this, the hashtag,
there's a live wave, there's a moderator questions
you can load up and all that kind of stuff.
It's also, my site, if you want to follow
me--so here it is so, tinyurl.com/push-io2010.
Okay, so, the agenda. So, we're going to have
a little intro. We're going to talk about--are
they okay? All right. We're going to talk
about publishing. We're going to talk about
subscribing. We're talking about what Hubs
are? How they work, what they are for? We
have a special guest, Julien Genestoux from
Superfeedr. He's going to talk Superfeedr
and what Superfeedr does and how that hooks
into all of this. Then we're going to talk
about some progress and adoption, and future
work and improvement and things that are kind
of are going on right now. So, intro; "What
is PubSubHubbub?" So, PubSubHubbub is a simple
topic-based publish and subscribe protocol.
It turns Atom and RSS feeds into real-time
streams, that's what it does. But it's a single
API for web-scale and low-latency messaging.
So, the idea is here is that we're making
it very easy for developers to add real-time
capabilities to their applications online,
their web apps. And in PubSubHubbub, there
are three participants; there's a Publisher,
who's publishing a feed of content or information.
There's a Subscriber who wants to get that
information, and then there's this Hub in
the middle. And the Hub is a logical component
but the idea, we're going in to some philosophical
things but the Hub is a facilitator of this
relationship, tries to make it as easy as
possible for Publishers and Subscribers to
work together. So some design goals. First
of all, we wanted to be decentralized. Some
of the things that existed in the past like
ping-o-matic; we're actually kind of centralized
systems. People have talked about feed mash
and some other ping technologies in the past.
But a lot of them, you know, had many points
of failure or single points of failure and
we're decentralized, we're in control of one
company. So first of all, we want it to be
an open spec that anyone can implement, have
a lot of different thesis working together
which is kind of how, what the web is built
on, right? The other thing is we wanted to
scale those sizes of the whole web. So, you
know, the web is built of with decentralized
protocols that scale up and can work in massive
scale. We wanted PubSubHubbub to work the
same way. We wanted to make publishing and
subscribing as easy as possible. So, that
it'd be very easy for you to get started with
the protocols, start adopting it and start
using it in your applications immediately.
And part of the reason we did that is because
we knew we wanted a critical mass of people
to use this so they would catch on and I'm
happy to say that we're starting to get there
which is great and we'll talk more about that
later. But in order to do that, in order to
make it easy for Publishers and Subscribers,
we decided to push any complexity towards
the Hub. So, anytime we can make it easier
for Publishers or Subscribers in their job
to build their applications. We decided to
kind of push things back up into this agent
called the Hub which facilitates this relationship,
and by doing that, we make it extremely easy
for Publishers and Subscribers to use the
protocol. The other thing is and for all the
XMPP folks in the room. XMPP, we understand
it, Brad's doing the server in it. It's something
that a lot of people like in using Google,
embraces in a lot of ways but, for whatever
reason, it hasn't necessarily caught on in
the way that everybody wants it to for publish
and subscribe at web-scale. And so, with PubSubHubbub,
what we've been trying to do is solve a kind
pragma, you know, taking a pragmatic approach
to this and solve the real problems that people,
developers are having everyday. So, you know,
there's a lot of things in PubSubHubbub that
are a little crafty or maybe don't have the
best usage of verbs and stuff like that and
the reason is that is pragmatic. So, it's
unnecessarily ideologically pure like a lot
of XMPP is where it's, you know, perfectly
balanced and well-thought out. And, but the
reason is that we wanted to make it easy to
implement the libraries, have the libraries
work with transparent proxies and so on and
so forth. All these practical considerations
that kind of override the ideological ones,
and we also wanted to leave out a kind of--we
want to leave some things on the table. So,
a lot of specs, you know, there'll be a one
pager and then a few people will have, you
know, there'll be one pager that handles 50%
of the use-cases, and then there'll be a two
pager that handles 75%, and then a three pager
that handles 80%, and you get this diminishing
returns. So another part of PubSubHubbub,
what we were trying to accomplish was, you
know, basically hit, dissolve, no new use-cases
that everybody has right now and a kind of
not to some things specifically so that we
could just get this protocol started and get
people using it. So, let's do a demo. Let's
see if this works. So here is, all right,
here is a whole bunch of apps. Let me just
click around. So this is, on the upper right
is FriendFeed; on the upper left is Google
Reader; in the middle here is Blogger; lower
left is Buzz; lower right is click set. And
I have a blog here that's connected to my
Buzz profile and it's also connected all these
other feed pieces. And so, I'm going to post
the feed now; Bloggers Hubbub enabled and
so are these other hosts. So when I click,
post, depending on how much time we've got.
Hey, there everyone, do you see that? Show
that, there it is. Let's see if it showed
up in Brett's test blog too and it's probably
here but it's not reloading because we got
a lot of traffic right now. Okay. So, you
already see that it's really quick from publish
to receive, right? We're trying to do real-time
web technologies, low-latency, massive distribution
and we already have a bunch of products, we
have bunch of different vendors here, it's
publishing and subscribing. I'm using Blogger
in this case but you could be using LiveJournal,
you could be using WordPress, you could be
using TypePad, so we got a lot of people allowing
it to publish and subscribe. All right, we'll
continue. So, a big question that we get is,
why another protocol, why another publish
and subscribe protocol? And, you know, almost
every company out there has their own system
for doing this and there's a lot of really
good ones out there. But a lot of the time
those internal systems for message queuing
are just kind of much more than you actually
need on the web. What we found is that what
probably on the web is basic topic base messaging,
and then so we need a level of content filtering
in terms of the robustness that it needs just
yet. They don't even realize what they need,
so it's hard to convince people of all these
extra features when you can't even get them
on board of any kind of PubSub integration.
So, we are trying to bridge the islands basically.
Take every company who's got an internal NQ
system and say, "Well, I know you're generating
events and I'm generating events but we use
different systems for our own business needs.
How can we connect them together in the way
that it's useful?" And if you look at a lot
of these that either have a proprietary messaging
payload or they have a standard that doesn't,
like a standard wire format that doesn't use
HTTP or can't be load balance, have different
network, topology needs. So there's a bunch
of issues for these systems that prevents
them from being massively integrated without
a lot of effort. So, people have tried to
standardize on simpler, a more simple topic
based messaging systems and other standards
like that. And so, you know, XMPP is one of
them and XEP-60 which is XMPP PubSub is a
great example of spec that really tried hard
to solve this PubSub need. But it's really
not used for interop beyond IM that widely.
Another one social web project that came out
of Vodafone research is trying to change that
and trying to do something new different and
I definitely think it's a good thing for you
to check out and look out some of the ideas
there. Maybe that they, maybe they'll be able
to get more traction of with what they're
doing. But in the end, this attempts that
a standard for doing messaging are kind of
overkill and they haven't been able to catch
on. And I can go through the list but, there's
a reason for almost each one, you know, of
why it's too much so, I'll just quick to say,
XEP-60 does a lot of stuff that a lot of people
don't need because they don't realize they
needed it yet. Or the WS-Star stuff is too
much, too XML heavy and people don't necessarily
want to do that. They just want to RESTful
interface. AMQPS is a different wire protocol,
you can't load balance in the same way. RestMS
has been fluctuating a lot, so it actually
hasn't been defined as a spec yet and the
rest of our stuff dictates URL parameters,
so that you, or URL paths so that I can't
decide how I want my URLs to look. So, we
tried to just avoid all of those issues as
much as we can. Okay, so quickly, how do you
do it? So, if you have a feed, an Atom feed,
an RSS feed, and you want to make that feed
real-time, you add the declaration to your
feed with the Hub of your choice or Hubs of
your choice so that could be the reference
Hub which I have here it could be Superfeedr,
and Julien will tell you more about that later.
Then you publish something to your feed, so
it's in the document and then you send the
ping with the feed URL to your Hubs, one or
more, you can use as many as you want. And
it's just a simple web from URL encoded payload
just like your browser would send, and you
say Hub mode is published and Hub URL this
is my feed. So, this is what I've updated.
If you get back a 204, no content that means
that the ping was received. If you get back
a 400 that means you did something wrong.
If you get back a 500 that means the server
is hurting or something, it did something
wrong. That's it. That's what we're talking
about, try to make it as easy as possible
for Publishers. This is so easy. You can do
it from a bookmark load. It's like ridiculously
easy. Some best practices, we'll get into
this more for later but, you actually can,
as a Publisher, do server-side filtering.
Just do it with the virtual feed I.D. or some
kind of conflict, a topic URL that encodes
some extra information. So, here if I have
my stuff app on example.com and I want to
find things in zip code here at the conference
center, that's a valid PubSubHubbub topic,
right? So you could subscribe to that. So,
it's not content filtering as much as it is
topic based subscription, right? So, there's
a lot of things you can encode in the URL.
If to deal with normalization some other stuff
but that's a best practice for you if you're
building out some really cool real-time feeds
for your site. Similarly, you can use URLs
for authorization. I'll get into this more
later but, by using one time tokens and other
kinds of crypto parameters, you can make those
URLs actually private to an individual. So
that if someone wants to syndicate, publish
updates to only the one user, you can give
them a URL that only works for them and then
Google Reader will only let them read their
own items, right? Okay, so, Subscribers, let's
say you want to get the updates. You know
there's a whole bunch of feeds out there and
you want to be able to get the data. So, somehow
you detect that there's a Hub declaration
in the feed. So if I go back, you see I added
this, link rel equals hub href equals the
Hub address. I put that in my Atom or RSS
document at the top level, feed level, or
kind of level element and that declares where
the Hubs are located. So, supposedly you've
come across the speed of the users inserted
the URL or you've done, spend auto discovery,
you've done some crawling, whatever, you found
that there's a feed you want to subscribe
to and in that feed you see that there's a
Hub link, so you're like, "Great, this has
PubSubHubbub." So I will send a subscribe
request to the feed's Hubs, one or more and
you could use multiple in the case of a liability.
In this case, you say, post, you know, post
to it again, form URL encode like a browser,
so this is a really simple kind of web-hook,
callback or web-hook calls. Again, you have,
you set the mode to subscribe. In this case,
you have to verify a parameter which says
if you want to do synchronous or asynchronous.
You say the topic feed that you want to subscribe
to and then the callback URL. So, when an
event happens on this feed, where do you callback?
The Hub will send a request to that callback
URL with little challenge string and a couple
of other things to verify that you are you
and all you have to do is echo back the random
string, and that's just how we guarantee,
that's how we authorize the callback and you
give a 200. Now once you do that, the subscription
setup, and every time that feed updates and
the Publisher pings that feed, the Hub will
go fetch it, figure out what's new and then
deliver a payload to your callback, that's
all there's to it. So this is just a feed,
I've kind of gathered it. And in a lot of
cases, the Hub will actually pull out old
items that you've seen before. So for speed,
you can actually have differential protocols,
so you only get new items or change items.
So let's talk about this magical Hub that
seems to make this so easy. So the Hub has
a few functions, it accepts and verifies subscriptions
like I just described. It receives pings from
the Publishers and retrieves a new contact,
that was first, the how to help Publishers.
All right, extracts new and updated items
from the feed, or sends the whole feed depending
on how it's implemented. And then it sends
all the subscribers a new content, so it does
the fan-out, right? It also have some DoS
protections built into it to make sure that
subscribers don't get overwhelmed and Publishers
don't get DoS and that kind of thing. It's
also a logical component, so Publishers can
be their own Hub. You can combine Hubs and
Publishers together to have like a peer to
peer speed up. You can also have different
agreements between the Hubs and Publishers
so that if you want to publish on thrift or
through JSON, if that's better your infrastructure,
you could do that that's outside of the boundary
of the spec. So, the relationship between
a Publisher and the Hub is actually totally
up in the air. It's not a specific requirement
of the protocol. The pinging that we've implemented
as part of the base spec was to bootstrap
the protocols so that people can start using
it immediately, so that you can ping from
a bookmark code for instance. But the Hub
is what's able to facilitate this relationship
provides scalability and reliability delivering
these messages and scaling them out. Okay.
So, now, I'm going to hand it over to Julien
Genestoux?
>> GENESTOUX: Genestoux.
>> SLATKIN: Genestoux, who's the main guy,
the superhero at Superfeedr. So, Julien.
>> GENESTOUX: Good to meet you. So basically
we're Superfeedr and we're a shop that helps
makes PubSubHubbub be something that is more
than just something at Google. And let me
go into a little bit more details. For this,
we provide a few stuff. We provide what we
call, first, the "Default hub." It's a Hub
that's works with basically any feed as Brett
just showed us. PubSubHubbub is a protocol
that needs to be declared in a feed. The Superfeedr
Hub works with any feed. So, if you're a subscriber,
you could say, "Hey, I want this content,
please push it to me." We will do stuff to
get that to you. The second thing we do is
"Hosted hubs." So we provide pretty much the
same thing as Google provides, for people
who don't want to use the Google Hub for whatever
reason that they might have. The last thing
we do is what we call "PubSubHubbub + Benefits."
So as Brett just showed us the bare protocol
is pretty easy and simple and we just add
a few layers on top of this and I'm going
to comeback to that later to make it better,
nicer, smarter, whatever you call it. So,
let's start with the Default Hub. So this
is actually the "Historical Supefeedr." Superfeedr
started last year, pretty much at the same
time. And, we were basically doing feed polling
on behalf of other people. So, say, you are
a big service that needs to segregate a lot
of content from the web. Instead of doing
that yourself, you would give us the URL and
we would do that for you. The goal is to,
as much as we can avoid polling though. For
that, we use different techniques like smart
scheduling. So, we try to determine when is
the best time to fetch a feed base on historical
values, historical updates based on what you
call feed graphs. So, for example, if you
have a FriendFeed account and a Twitter account,
when we see an update in your Twitter stream,
we might assume that your FriendFeed is going
to be updated and that you have linked the
two together. So, we all do this graphing
to, you know, basically how updates propagate.
We also so stuff like "Protocol mapping."
Last summer, there was a big fight between
PubSubHubbub and RSSCloud. Things pretty much
over now but, we basically implemented the
two because we thought that subscribers shouldn't
choose or at least shouldn't have to implement
all of them or choose to implement just a
few of them. By implementing one, we would
be basically map that to any feed. So we implemented
our SUP, which is a protocol that was made
by FriendFeed, XML-RPC, a few other stuff.
We do push to Subscriber, pretty much exactly
what Brett described. And we also do XMPP,
which Brett just trashed, but it's great.
But it's actually a great protocol. It has
definitely some pretty steep learning curve,
I would say. But once you get it, it's pretty
powerful. And we do, last thing, which is
the Schema mapping. In a nutshell, as a Subscriber,
you shouldn't have to care whether the original
feed is item RSS, RSS0.92 or whatever. Or
even if it's not valid, we just do the hard
work for you of having mapping everything
into the same consistent format so your application
just have to consume that and do whatever
is that you do best. So, basically, that's
the point here is focus on what you do best
and we'll do the rest. A few use-cases, people
who actually use the default hub, there is
a bunch of iPhone Apps that can send you notification
while you're at a conference, for example.
We help them get content from feeds, so Urban
Airship is an example, Boxcar is another example.
They're obviously feed readers. You guys already
know of Webwag or Feedingo which are, they're
pretty nice application. We have desktop notification
so, your desktop application would subscribe
to Superfeedr to get updates and then ping
you on the desktop Google-–sorry, Adobe
made a product called Wave last year that
does this. We have also a few semantic search
customers. We are, basically, they need to
have a lot of data rather than spending time
gathering it. We just do that for them, push
it to them and then they do their magic, Guzzle.it
and Twingly! are good example. And then there's
also a social web. Social Apps that might
want to aggregate all your data from x social
service, might not just want to subscribe
you all of the feeds and, well, just give
us the URL and we'll fetch them for them on
their behalf. And the second thing we do is
the Hosted Hubs. The idea is like if you're
a Publisher, you shouldn't have to reinvent
the wheel nor that you should have to run
the wheel yourself. You just can't use somebody
who does it for you, and that's pretty much
what we do. So, you're a Publisher and you
have feeds rather than implementing the protocol
or use or should I say download and then sell
your own version of some open source code.
Just give us like the pings and we'll care
about the rest. It's, on the other hand, we
think it's, since it's your Hub, it needs
to be your data. So we of like full expert
of the data at anytime, et cetera. So it's
really like running your own without any hassle
and any maintenance or any debugging that
you would have to do. For quite a few cherries
on the cake, like analytics, callbacks, meaning
like you might, as a Publisher, you might
say, hey, PubSubHubbub is great but I don't
want to allow primers to get my content as
soon as it published it, it doesn't make sense.
So, I want make their life not as easy as
PubSubHubbub make it. So, I want to know upon
subscription with subscribing to what and
this is what we actually implemented. A few
reference for Hubs that we host. Buzz or Tumblr
in the blogging field, social networks like
Gowalla, Ping.fm, Media, Gawker, Huffington
Post and there are a lot more to come. And
going back to the Schema Mapping, this is
one of the things that we do and that I think
it's very important. Obviously, there is,
as I said tons of different format and as
a Subscriber, you might not want to deal with
pub date in RSS for the published dates and
published in item or even updated sometime
in item. Or even like pub dates because there's
a typo in the feed, we will do that for you.
The other thing is there's a ton of different
namespaces out there and some of them are
very redundant. The Digg, the Mixx and the
Yahoo Buzz have their own namespace, which
is basic--the information, the semantic is
the same. It's voting on a story and the number
of votes. Why would you have to have six different
namespaces of Subscriber and implement all
of them? So we just make sure that it's always
easy for you to consume the data. We have
to secure about the ton of invalid stuff and
there's pretty good stories about this but
basically missing tags, wrong dates and other
calendars like we've got our big dates and
we need to tell you, "Hey, this happened in
13th century." This is actually not the case
so, we need to figure that out. Unique IDs
that are not unique. We've seen pretty much
a lot Publisher putting timestamps in unique
IDs, which kind of kills the purpose. We also
do stuff like Geo-RSS. So we can push you
the data until you, "Hey, this is basically
the geo coordinates of where it happened."
And we also do, for the social web, Activity
Streams. So, as a consuming application, you
know the verb, the activity, I mean, the verb
and the object that I concern very specific
activity. We, on top of PubSubHubbub also
provide a few extensions. One of them that
we just launched last week is what we called
Digest Notification. So the problem with most
of PubSubHubbub protocol is like it, they
fail silently. If I tell you, "Hey, wait here,
I'm going to tell when there is something
new," and I just go on vocation for like two
weeks. You're going to wait because you've
assumed that I'm going to tell you while--no
matter what, I'm gone, so you can wait for
a long time, it won't happen. So we implemented
what we call Digest Notification, which serves
two purposes, Heartbeat, so we can tell you,
"Hey, no matter what, you're going to get
an update every 24 hours." And Digest, so
that if by any chance you miss anything during
the day, you know what has happened and you
can actually catch up. We also implement a
few other stuff like Feed status so you can
query Superfeedr to know what is the current
content of the feed so it's much easier for
you if you have been on vacation for two weeks
to comeback and say, "Hey, what did I miss?"
We have subscription callback that I just
mentioned where you can, as a Publisher, decide
whether you want to allow subscription or
not from a specific user. And the last thing
we are implementing is called Virtual feeds.
So, let's assume a small use-case where you
would subscribe to a feed from, I don't know,
Craig's list on the San Francisco car search
and you might say, "Hey, I just don't want
San Francisco, I also want San Mateo and like-–sorry,
and, I don't know, some other town in the
area, Oakland. We would do basically a virtual
feed that combines the information from the
three so that, as a Subscriber, you don't
have to subscribe like three times to three
different sources. In terms of the Superfeedr
Infrastructure, we're basically a Botnet.
It's an old, this is an independent component,
little XMPP workers, I love XMPP, that connects
say, "Hey, give me work" and then some other
distribute the work to them and they do what
they have to do, and then at some point in
time like everybody here. The good thing about
this is like we, I mean, we're like if something
is wrong, it's never long, it's never wrong
longer than the lifetime of one single worker
so it's not that bad. For the polling, we
have an interesting thing, which is a massive
"Ring." So the polling, it has to be scheduled.
So, at anytime, we know, "Hey, we need to
fetch this feed now, this one in 10 minutes
and this one in like half an hour." So, we've
build this infrastructure, which is a huge
"Ring." So, basically, we take an item in
the "Ring" and then put it in the back again
so it makes a big loop and which is, we try
to run this loop as fast we can; we're currently
like do 70,000 feeds a second. And then we
have a lot of caches to make the diffs. So,
as Brett explained, the PubSubHubbub protocol,
the Hub is suppose to fetch the feed and see
what is new versus what is old, and this is
something that's pretty hard to do when you
start having millions of feeds and you need
to be able to diff very efficiently so we
use a lot of cache mechanisms and cluster
to do that. A few number of distributionary
infrastructure. We push, we currently push
content to about 1.8 million endpoints, that's
about 20 million entries, item entries a day
just for the reference. In Twitter, in February,
said that they were publishing about 50 million
tweets a day, so it's pretty much, I mean,
it's slightly smaller but I'm pretty sure
like in three months we're going to be bigger
than them. We have about 50 hosted Hubs, 45
dispatchers that send information to the Subscriber,
80 parsers and that's about 50 servers at
the moment. In terms of growth, here, you
have the number of subscription that we've
had over, since January 1st, it's by week,
and it's, as you can see, it's pretty much
going very, very fast. We expect to be like
three million before the end of June. A few
TODO before I leave you back with Brett, make
your feeds real-time. This is really, really
important. Make them in real-time and we can
help, so ask me. For those Superfeedr on Twitter,
say hello to @julien51, which me too on Twitter,
Pick Stickers, I've pretty much for everybody,
I think and thank you very much.
>> SLATKIN: Great, thanks a lot, Julien. Cool.
So, let's, I guess, that's great to see another
independent company doing some really cool
stuff with PUbSubHubbub in helping a lot of
other companies do a lot of really cool stuff
with real-time feeds. And so I want to talk
more about the kind of progress in the community
of PubSubHubbub adoption thus far. So, there's
actually over a 100 million feeds that are,
PubSubHubbub enabled, and we have companies
like Superfeedr and their friends, all the
different companies they've been enabled the
logos that Julien are showing you, plus Google,
Six Apart, LiveJournal, MySpace, TwitterFeed,
Netvibes, Cliqset, Gnip, PostRank and a bunch
of other kind of companies like Radian6 are
all using PubSubHubbub for kinds of scanning
and all kinds of search based intelligence
stuff. In terms of Google products, we have
full integration with Google Buzz that means
that with Google Buzz both, your feeds are
going out like the feed of your buzzes and
for connected sites that you connect to your
profile. Google Buzz will actually use PubSubHubbub
to receive those updates. So, when I showed
you my demo earlier and I posted the Blogger
the reason that got there so quickly was because
Gmail is, you know, or the Google Buzz is
subscribed to my feed using PubSubHubbub.
So, if I've done the same thing from LiveJournal,
you would have seen the same thing. So, Buzz,
it's great, you can do in and out in this,
a much more stuff around the Buzz API today.
We also do it for common feeds and tag feeds,
so you should check that out. With integration
with FeedBurner, so this is if you ping FeedBurner
after updating your source feed, FeedBurner
will fetch your source feed. It'll burn the
feed as a proxy adding whatever stats you
what and advertisements or whatever I'll see
use FeedBurner for. And then it will publish
your feed using PubSubHubbub to notify subscribers.
So, if you're using FeedBurner, chances are
you already have this enabled for your feed
and you just don't know it. And a lot of the
infrastructure that you've already had to
ping FeedBurner with your updates is being
reuse to make your feed real-time. So I suggest
you go check out your feed and see what's
there and experiment with it and we're making
process to make FeedBurner better at doing
this, integrate better with SuperFeedr and,
you know, basically a lot, everyone will provide
better stats about subscription and publishing.
Like I said, we have Blogger immigration,
Reader shared items so both of the published
feeds there are real-time through PubSubHubbub.
One that's really cool is Google Alerts. So
you can sign up for a feed with Google Alerts
and you can subscribe at that feed using PubSubHubbub.
That doesn't mean as soon as something is
added to the Google Index, it shows up on
the feed but it's actually really low-latency,
it can be scary low-latency sometimes. So,
you should definitely check that out. Fastflip
also which is a news product, Google News
product will publish new updates using PubSubHubbub.
And there's a bunch more stuff on the way.
Oh, I want to give a plug really quickly.
Tomorrow, I think, at 1 o'clock there's another
session here at Google I/O for [INDISTINCT]
are having a kind of real-time AJAX APIs and
App Engine API talk and it's talking about
the new feeds API, which has real-time capabilities
and also the real-time and browser push for
API for App Engine. So, if you're interested
in how Google is making it easier for the
developers to add PubSubHubbub subscription
to their, to your applications, I definitely
recommend you go check that the talk out and
learn about it. So, yeah, Julien had some
great numbers from his, from the Superfeedr
Hub. I want to--they also come out with some
cool numbers from reference Hub. And, again,
the reference Hub is an open source implementation
of the PubSubHubbub protocol. It runs on App
Engine. It's written in Python, it's open
source. You could search for PubSubHubbub
as the first link you can find it; so it's
interesting. So we're doing about 200 plus
feed fetches per second, it's kind of our
average peak. We're delivering 250 plus items
per second. That's just items, that's not
necessarily multiplied by the number of subscribers,
it gets a lot larger if you do that. And we
have 70 million active subscriptions and we
deliver 1.2 billion items since July of last
summer. And so, what's really, that's about
50 items per second and the traffic keeps
ramping up and up and up. So, if you average
it out, it's 50 items per second I think.
Yeah. And then, but, anyway, it's getting
up there. So, really happy with the uptake,
really happy at the Hub and App Engine scaling
really well. And like Julien was saying, it's
interesting comparing traffic numbers to say
like Twitter to PubSubHubbub and both, you
know. We are working on different feed, you
know, different feed providers and different
publishers so we get to add our numbers together
because we're part of decentralized system
where they don't, right? So that's pretty
cool to see the decentralization and network
effects kind of coming into play. So here's
that site pubsubhubbub.googlecode.com, you
spell it however you want. I promise you'll
find it, nothing else like that. We have clients
for you to use immediately. So if you're publishing
Peril, PHP, basically everything will sit
in here including Haskell for all you guys.
You know who you are. We've got it for you.
There's subscriber clients for PHP, .NET,
Scala and Zend framework and a whole bunch
of other things. I think some of the coolest
ones I've seen, I think the Drupal module
is really good. If you're doing anything with
PHP with Drupal at these feeds module by Alex
Barth that's really awesome. It does, basically,
everything you could want to do on the Subscriber
side that can also deal with PubSubHubbub
notifications and works very well with Superfeedr,
so I will definitely check that out. There
are Hubs, there's the App Engine reference
one both hosted and not, there's Superfeedr--I'm
talking about source code here that's why
Superfeedr is not in this list. We have WordPress
has an open-source implementation of a Hub
that they run for their hosted blogs and for
blogs that you host yourself. There's one
written in Erlang that actually will bridge,
so it's part of, it's actually, we're on top
of RabbitMQ, so it's called Rabbit Hub. It's
written in Erlang and they'll actually bridge
from RabbitMQ, anything RabbitMQ will connect
to in the PubSubHubbub and back again. So,
they've got all kinds of crazy transports.
They leave in transport to SMTP if you want
them to, so definitely check that out. We've
got a mailing list with 440 members or more.
A lot of members of community, a lot of discussion
there about new ideas and problems and so
on, so I invite you to come and join and bring
your questions and participate. Like Julien
is saying, there are more publishers on the
way, more subscribers and more Hubs coming,
which is great. So, this is, that's kind of
the beginning part of it, kind of, the state
of the union and everything has happened and
what's going on in adoption and so on. I wanted
to talk a little bit about kind of the future
work and where we're going with this. We've
got a lot of traction and momentum built-up
and we're hoping to keep it going. So, I wanted
to talk about kind of what the next steps
are and what we have in progress. So, the
big one that we keep hearing from people is
arbitrary content support, so, arbitrary content
type support. So, I don't know if you saw
Facebook's real-time API that just came out
at F8 conference but, it used about half of
the PubSubHubbub protocol for doing real-time
notifications, which is great. It uses WebHooks,
it uses the same verification protocol, but
they needed a different payload type and they
need authentication and among a couple other
smaller things. And this is something that
Brett and I have been talking about and working
on for long times figuring out exactly how
we wanted to do it. And what we wanted to
do, to start off was just do feeds extremely
well and we're getting there and we're starting
to do that well enough that it's getting critical
mass. So now we're ready to kind of move on
to the next pieces of this so, we'll give
you some use-cases. So, the microformats people,
they're interesting guys and they say, why
would you ever have semantic data like they
don't believe in RDF, they don't believe in
XML, they don't believe in things that parse
correctly, which I think is actually, you
know, make it human readable first and then
machine readable, you know, second. And I
think it's an interesting approach and it
definitely works really well. I don't know
if you've seen any integration of microformats
in the Google search results like recipes
and dates each contacts or each cards but
it's actually really cool what microformats
does. So, they've got something called hAtom
where they want to take an HTML document,
mark it up with some semantic tags that say,
"Well, this is actually an Atom feed." Even
though it looks like an HTML doc and this
is post number one with this ID and this is
post number two with this ID, so they can
overlay an HTML document from presentation
with the feed and make it to the--it has both
a human presentation and semantic meaning.
So they'd like to use PubSubHubbub for the
delivery because they want, you know, the
real-time things integrate with the, you know,
microformats that they love so much, so they
want an HTML push. Google, we really care
a lot about indexing, so does Microsoft, with
Bing and so does Yandex with their search
engine. And so, you know, Sitemaps is a way
that the whole kind of search and indexing
industry, you know, finds out about new content
and especially for breath. And so, you know,
we would like to be able to push updates for
XML sitemaps so that when you update your
site and your sitemaps and you have some very
deep pieces of content to get updated that
don't get crawled very often, you can ping
and say, "My sitemaps is updated." And all
the crawlers of the world will know that and
go and fetch the latest content. But they
need to get the whole sitemap with all the
different URLs and whatnot and understand
that they need to fetch it. So, Google wants
to be able to do XML pushing for that. And
then, JSON as the Facebook case. They'd like
to push some JSON data through there. A lot
of the Activity Streams people will also want
to be able to push JSON for the Activity Streams
representation in JSON. And that also is easier
for developers to use in a lot of cases. So,
our plan is to build on some of the LRDD or
lard or however you want to say it, web linking
stuff, if you just search for LRDD, there's
a nice document. Basically, it says how to
use a link header in an HTTP response to indicate
where the Hub is. So that means that if you're
serving, say, a JPEG image and you want to--maybe
it's your Avatar and you want people to be
able to subscribe the updates to your Avatar.
How would they do that? Well, they'd go and
fetch your Avatar and then a response and
see a link rel equals hub, hub equals blahdiblah.
So, it'd be the same kind of semantics like
we saw on the feed but for any HTTP resource,
right? And then you'd be able to subscribe
to that resource on that Hub and then it tell
you time it's updated, you'll be notified
with the full payload of the updated data.
So, that's what we were planning on building
on. We're working on, you know, building at
the Hub and figuring out the protocols. We've
got a lot of really good feedback from the
people at Facebook about what they want in
this regard and it's awesome. I mean, this
is what the community interior view is all
about, so that's really cool to see. The other
thing that we're working on is private feeds.
So this is something a common misconception
that people have about PubSubHubbub is that
it only works for public feeds. Well, that
certainly what we've been trying to get adoption
on because for, because that's most of what's
out there. But, you actually can use PubSubHubbub
with private feeds if you know the right approach.
And, so, our plan is to basically achieve
all of these goals. We wanted to be fully
encrypted. We want authorization of the subscriber
and we want it to be authenticated by directionally.
We want to integrate with some of the other
tools out there for oath like OAuth, RelMeAuth
and WebFinger. And then we want people to
be able to use the same technology for both
private feeds and for other means. So, for
instance, if you want to apply business policies
like say, "Okay, I want to authenticate my
subscriber so that I know that they don't
subscribe to more than 100 different things,"
you know? That's how you maybe you can enforce
your business model if you wanted to. So,
you should be able to do that and Superfeedr
kind of does this with the, an extension that
they've built were they say, "Well, you know,
the Subscriber has to authenticate because
I want to make sure that spammers don't get
my content." It's like, understandable and
authentication or private feeds are one way
to achieve that. The other big thing is that
we want to be able to achieve per item privacy
control. Now, one of the first things that
people come up with when they say, "How are
we going to do private content in Atom feeds
or PubSubHubbub?" They say, well, okay, what
if we just didn't actually put the content
in there but we put like a little marker that
said there was content. Like there something
private here and here's the timestamp and
the ID, go fetch it over here with your authentication
header and we'll give you access. Well, I
mean, that's definitely an engineer solution
to the problem, but it has a bunch of problems.
The biggest problem it has is this idea of
plausible deniability. Now I'm not planning
on stealing anything from the 7-Eleven down
the street. But, you know, if I checked in
at 7-Eleven, let's say, and, you know, using
Foursquare or Gowalla, even if that content
were private, it puts me in a location or,
at least, the fact that the event happened
causes me to be associated with the time and
place. So if it's three in the morning and
I checked in with Gowalla or some other location
based service and that's, just the fact that
it's communicated that the event came through
at 3 a.m. ties me to of time and place. And
I'm not saying that people are going to be,
you know, committing any crimes or anything
like that but I think it's extremely important
to, when you're talking about privacy you
really need to respect privacy and you need
to be able to enforce plausible deniability,
that's [INDISTINCT] test in my mind. So, the
solution of private feeds that we're working
towards us also being inputted in force, plausible
deniability so that the feed, if you don't
have access to the item, you don't even know
the item exists. So the simple way that we're
kind of going at this is we're saying that
each subscriber will actually have a unique
URL that they subscribe to, so that on the
Hub side, the Hub will understand the actual
authentication that is available. So, what
I mean is, if both me and Julien have access
to the same items then the Hub will send us
both the same items. But the Hub understands
who we are and what our ACLs are, okay? So,
that an item comes in from the Publisher that
only Julien has access to it and I don't have
access to, then the Hub knows to only send
it to him and not send it to me. So in the
same sense that we're, original philosophy
of PubSubHubbub was to say put the complexity
in the center. Put in the Hub so the Hub understands
the really difficult parts, we're going to
do that again. We're going to say the Hub
has to understand the ACLs of the feeds that
are subscribed to and the equivalence between
those feeds and then fan it out per item to
the Subscriber as need be. So we're getting
more into the scaling issues here, the actual
design. We think we can make the scale properly
and that's part of why it's been taking so
long is making sure that we kind of take a
rigorous look at the design to make sure it'll
scale. But the hope is that we'll be able
to have fully authenticated feeds so that
the idea of having Google Buzz get location
data from Gowalla and have it be fully authenticated
in private without any kind of ACL issues
so we can actually have that decentralize
to the future. So that's what we're working
towards, it's a big thing. So, if you're interested
in that, please join the mailing list and
talk to us. So, some further reading. So OStatus
is something that's really cool. If you've
done any of the other social track stuff today
you've kind of heard about the pieces that
are in OStatus, Salmon, Webfinger, PubSubHubbub
and Activity Streams and Portable Contacts.
OStatus is an interesting approach to this
from the status.net and Identi.ca guys, it's
definitely worth the read just because it's
a very interesting investigation into building
decentralized protocols. The Buzz API you
should definitely check out. Kind of division
for the Buzz API is that Buzz is just one
island amongst many and those islands are
able to talk together. So, we are working
on, you know, at Google, decentralized social
networks that can actually speak with each
other so that's a really cool point of reference.
And the Facebook real-time API, you should
definitely check out what they're doing there,
it's a very clean API. The use-cases are very
understandable and so it's definitely worth
checking out and seeing some, you know, comparing
and contrasting their needs versus the spec
as is and kind of seeing, you know, where
things are going to go. All right. So, you
can view live notes and ask questions on this
wave, that's where I am, Superfeedr and Julien
are at superfeedr.com. We're going to open
the floor to questions and I'm going to open
up, I'm going to click this button, I don't
know what's going to happen. So, I'm going
to go, I'm going to go over here because this
probably not going to be good. So, let see.
So, yeah, if there's any question there's
a mic right here. And if you have any questions
for me or Julien, if you'd like to runaway,
it's okay, go ahead this is the last session,
so. All right. So, okay. All right, this first
question goes, Brett, what kind of volume
are you seeing in the reference Hub? I hope
you'll answer that. So, a lot. Another one
is, do the Subscriber publish your needs to
renew the subscription periodically or does
it keep going forever? So, part of the PubSubHubbub
protocol is something called automatic or
periodic refreshing. So, it's actually on
the Hub to notify the Subscriber of how long
their subscription will last and then also
to refresh that subscription for the Subscriber
before that period. And basically the Hub
can refresh the subscription whenever they
want just to make sure that you're still there.
If you have a lot of drops, they want to make
sure you're still there. So the Subscriber
doesn't need to periodically double check
its subscription. And there are things like
what Julien is doing is extensions that Superfeedr
has for Digest and Hearbeat for people who
are extremely paranoid about missing an update
and these are interesting things that we might
look to incorporate in the protocol as an
extension to the protocol going forward because
it is a common concern. But, in the base protocol
right now, you should be able to trust the
Hub that the Hub is delivering that content
on behalf of the Publisher and that the Publisher
trust that Hub to do that, so you shouldn't
have to do that. Yup, question?
>> ORTIZ: Hi, Jorge Ortiz, UC Berkeley. I
was wondering if there were message time delivery
constraints since you say it's real-time?
And would I be guaranteed that I'm not going
to get a message, you know, a day late for,
you know, what's the variability in that?
>> SLATKIN: So, you're talking about at the
protocol level? Are you talking about just...?
>> ORTIZ: At the protocol level, you know.
>> SLATKIN: No.
>> ORTIZ: Okay.
>> SLATKIN: There's nothing and I think that
part of what, you know, we're doing is with
the reference implementation is just doing
the best we can.
>> ORTIZ: Yeah.
>> SLATKIN: And, we, you know, we have an
open Hub because we're just trying to boost
adoptions as much as possible but, Julien,
do you have...?
>> GENESTOUX: Yeah, we basically have the
same, like we don't have, for ping thing,
we don't have a guaranteed delay. For the
polling, so for the Default Hub, we can guarantee
15 minutes. So, if we have no way to know
if there's anything new, we're going to pull
every 15 minutes. But for the hosted Hub,
for the core protocol, no, we can't guarantee
anything yet. I hope we can soon.
>> Have you done any measurements to see what
the message variability is, or is that not
a concern right now?
>> SLATKIN: So, we have a series of probes
that we run on the reference Hub all the time
to see what the latency is. And I don't have
the graph here but, you know, we try to shoot
for a window and, you know, we have spikes
here and there about two minute, but usually
we stay underneath 10 seconds at all times.
>> Oh, Okay.
>> SLATKIN: And, but, you know, there's some
variability in there but it's pretty consistent.
I think though that there's also drops and
we're not measuring drops as accurately, so
full drops are also an important metric that
we want to get out there. But, I think these
is all developing and, you know, as people
go along to realize that this is core infrastructure
they can build on, that will make liability
and retries even more of a stronger guarantee.
So, for instance, if you had a Google Doc
that, you know, that, every time it updated,
you wanted an update through some PubSubHubbub
notification, you want to guarantee that that's
going to get there. So, at that point there's
actually business need and a requirement and
you're saying, I'm a developer I'm going to
bet on this. And so then we have to actually
provide at least some kind of an SLA like,
you know, like hopefully an SLA eventually
but also just to guarantee saying, like, hey,
if you don't get this, like, it's really,
it's our bad.
>> Right, so, that was sort of what I was
getting at was whether there's an SLA description
or anything like that.
>> SLATKIN: Yeah, it's still way too early
for that, but I think that, obviously, that's
what we really love to get there. If it was
so important that people want an SLA, that's
awesome.
>> Great.
>> SLATKIN: Yeah.
>> Thanks.
>> SLATKIN: Yup.
>> Yeah, I'm wondering which browsers support
the PuSH?
>> SLATKIN: Oh, you should go to the talk
tomorrow so that, and like I said, that's
not actually part of the PubSubHubbub protocol
that's a tool that Google is providing the
people. My understanding is that it's all
browsers. And I think including IE6 maybe,
yeah, IE6 for you. You've got it.
>> You mentioned this could be an alternate
to XMPP, right? So one of the main things
that XMPP provide is presence, so how does
this support it?
>> SLATKIN: Yeah, that's a really good question
and I think that, it doesn't provide presence,
right. And that's why this is not solving
the same problems that XMPP are. XMPP is really
good at solving the last mile problem and
presence that's why Google uses it for stuff
like Google Talk and for Wave. So, when you
really need... Yeah, we could have a feed
of your presence, we definitely could do that,
but, like, that wasn't the initial point.
We're trying to do server-to-server integration,
right. So, like, XMPP is really good at holding
up at single connection like down to a mobile
phone and then doing presence notifications.
But, I mean, if you, I would love to see someone
try--yeah, I mean, build the feed of presence
notification if you could. But XMPP is really
good at that right now, and...
>> GENESTOUX: I think, Brett's point is great
like any, I mean, we think like a lot of,
I mean, for example, it's very simple and
since you use feed you can actually represent
so many different information with feeds that
you can do presence with feeds over PubSubHubbub.
Like, I mean, obviously, like, I'm applying
it to, a raw feed, right, so you can definitely
make some kind of presence like information
via PubSubHubbub.
>> SLATKIN: Yeah.
>> GENESTOUX: Another use-case that we've
seen recently is synched between two services.
So you just mentioned Google Doc, so, say
you have Google Doc on one side and Dropbox
on the other side, it would be awesome that
every time I update my Google Doc, it just
saves to Dropbox. And every time I put a file
in to Dropbox, it just upload it to Google
Doc as well. And this can be done very easily
with PubSubHubbub actually. The only requirement
is like both services need feeds and they
just subscribe to each other, and then you
can have sync data across as many services
as you want.
>> SLATKIN: Yeah, and all of the stuff like
idempotents and deduping and update time and
all that stuff is figured out by Adam, in
the Adam, you know, format. So, you get all
the goodness of kind of Adam. And you could
even apply stuff like the feed sync protocol
that Microsoft developed on top of that for
even more robust synchronization mechanism.
>> One more thing. So is the reference and
implementation is something can that we can
use internally rather than in, as a hosted
model?
>> SLATKIN: Yeah, internally only, right,
behind the firewall?
>> Yes.
>> SLATKIN: Yes, so, I guess talk to Julien
and there's open source Hubs you see out there,
you could run those behind the firewall for
locally addressable feeds also if that was
something you're interested in, so. I think
that answers your question, maybe, so. Yeah,
yes.
>> I'm wondering if the protocol say something
about, you know, a Publisher gone rouge like
sending like too many updates; how to handle
that, any recommendations?
>> SLATKIN: Yeah, yeah. There's so there's
a thread on some of the public list I think
just yesterday and, yes, so if the publisher
start sending like a thousand pings a second
and the hub doesn't know what to do with them,
how do you prevent the publisher from DoSing
the hub? So, first of all, hopefully the publisher
and the Hub have a decent relationship with
each other that's kind of the assumption because
the Publisher is trusting the Hub to deliver
their content. So, the incentives aren't necessarily
there for a Publisher to DoS their own Hub,
right. But, let's say you did that anyway.
I think it's important best practice of just
having a website to have DoS protection and
this isn't no way different. So part of the
reference Hub has a DoS protection element
where they'll actually do counting of IPs
and requests over. It kind of leaky bucket
kind of thing to make sure that there aren't
too many pings and that slow feeds aren't,
don't have a negative effect on the Hub's
health, so I think that that's just a general
strategy anyone can use. It's not codified
with protocol but, it is kind of an HTTP.
Like if you get a 503 backoff then you should
backoff or else you're going to get black
hold. So I think that, you know, I don't necessarily
think we have to add it as the protocol but,
it could be something in the best practices
to say like don't, you know, if you're a Publisher
or if you're a Hub, you know, implement DoS
protections to make sure that you don't get
screwed.
>> So, basically, the Publisher will find
out that, you know, through the 503 or whatever
that they have...
>> SLATKIN: Yeah, that they need to rate limit
themselves basically, yeah, 503 retry after,
you know, that's, I mean, that's what the
reference Hub does right now. The more interesting
case that I've seen is the Subscribers just
over subscribing. You know, Subscribers subscribing
in a 100 requests per second. It's happening
right now on the reference Hub and, you know,
they get 503s all day long and it doesn't
hurt anybody, except for my bandwidth at all,
which I don't pay, so it's okay, so. Yeah?
>> Yes, similar question. So, how do you prevent
me setting a callback that is a ping URL for
another Hub that's decentralized and then
setting a callback that's a ping Hub does
ping your URL for your Hub which would create
like cyclical, but it's decentralize so you
don't have any common...
>> GENESTOUX: Generally, the Hub doesn't trust
the Publisher so it's light ping. So whenever
a Hub gets a ping, it will just fetch the
feed and see if there's anything new actually
and then you can take measures if you trying
to ping me for content that is not there.
You might want to block this URL or whatever.
But, the Hub doesn't trust a Publisher yet.
>> SLATKIN: Right, and so, and that's one
of the core design goals we had when designing
a protocol does not requiring authentication
between Hub and the Publisher. You just send
a light ping and it's, like, if you actually
served that feed then I will go to you. I
will use SSL to authenticate verified the
[INDISTINCT] on and on, and then that's my
authentication. I don't need to authenticate
the pinger. But, you can get some efficiencies
out of fat pinging but that's not defined
as part of the protocol. It's up to you how
you want to integrate with your Hub to do
that. We do something internally for that,
other people might want to do something else
and so we're just kind of leaving that undefined
so that people can just do what they want.
>> GENESTOUX: For some Hubs that we host,
we actually implemented the API of the Publisher
so that we actually subscribe to their content
through this, their own API rather than just
pull them in, they don't ping us. But, again,
this is the Publisher-Hub relationship. This
is part of the protocol but I think this is
probably something that is kind of on the
margin of that much of key and hold the key
all the time.
>> SLATKIN: Yeah. I think we got time for
one more but, I don't see any and I don't
see anything here. So, all right. Well, thanks
a lot for coming. If you have anymore questions,
we'll be here.